okay so we're back uh
some more discussion of the bootstrap we
saw an example of the bootstrap with the
investments
and now in general we're going to talk
about the bootstrap and think about it
in more complex situations so here's a
schematic which i think is very useful
actually it's uh due to david friedman
at berkeley
it's the real world bootstrap world view
of the boot of the bootstrap
so on the left we have a cloud
and the ingredients
we're imagining there's a population
a troop a real population that
um gives our data
which i'm calling generically z
observations e1 through zn
and from these are like our training
data right that's our training data for
example in the investment
example we just saw this this training
data was a set of
investments x y
x 1
y 1 2 x
and y n
all right but we'll call that
going to call each of these pairs a z z
one and up through z zn
so
we imagined in that situation that we
have our training data from a population
of investments
um this is in the real world right we we
have a training sample and from that
training example we derived
a statistic an estimate in that or a
particular case it was the the alpha hat
which is the proportion of investments
the optimal proportion of estimates for
um for x so this is a summary in the
sense of what we did in the investment
example
for our trading data
and what we wanted to get was a an idea
of the standard error of alpha hat
now and we made the point earlier that
ideally if we had had access the
population would get more training data
we could simply
grab more samples of training data from
the population more investments
from the possible population investments
you mean like a new sample the same size
exactly a new sample
and from the new sample do the same
analysis get an estimate alpha hat and
do that many times
and we showed how you can do that on the
computer
in the previous example but made the
point that not often can you actually do
that in practice because you don't have
access to the population you can't get
more training data typically
what you have to work with is just your
your given trading sample so the
bootstrap the a way of thinking of the
bootstrap in in the abstract to say well
we don't have access to population let's
replace the population which we don't
have by
p hat
which in the boothstraps case is
um
it's the training sample itself it's a
population that has puts probability 1
over n
and being the sample size on each of the
training points so it says our guess for
the population which we don't have
access to but we have from a training
sample
is
if we have no more information we're
going to say with equal probability that
a training point can come from
the first point we saw the second point
we saw up to the nth point we saw so
that's what called p hat
the empirical distribution function
that's another name for that
empirical distribution function
so when you draw from this empirical
distribution function
that is sampling
with replacement
and that's what the bootstrap does right
it samples
we saw that with we draw samples with
replacement from the training sample
that's this random sampling here p hat
giving z star this is not the bootstrap
sample remember we're going to use a
superscript star to indicate a bootstrap
sample
as distinct from a training sample which
has no superscript
so
this is one bootstrap draw this the
sample of size n
from our training sample now a bootstrap
sample giving us a bootstrap data
and from that we derive the estimate
again in this case it's
alpha
and we call alpha hat star
so bootstrap sampling simply repeats
this operation a few hundred times say
for each time we get a bootstrap sample
of size n and we get a bootstrap
um quantity alpha hat star
and then the standard error of alpha hat
star is our the bootstrap estimate of
standard error of alpha hat
so there's nothing there's nothing new
here we're simply describing what we
already saw in more general terms
okay but
um we can now think about how we would
carry this out in more complex
situations
so in general we need to figure out how
we can carry out bootstrap sampling
for example suppose we have a time
series
so
let's draw the
time axis here
and we have a series like for example
stock price
and let's just draw some imaginary
data
right
okay so this is
start let's call y1 this is the stock
price of time 1 stock price of time 2
etc
and we we want for example to to um to
predict the stock price from a given day
for a given day from the previous day
stock price so we'll fit a model a
regression model like we've seen to each
each stock price as a function of the
previous
stock price in the previous day
well that's fine we can do that we can
do that by least squares
and but now we might imagine doing
bootstrap sampling the way we just
described where we sample with
replacement from the data well one
problem with that that's a significant
problem is that the data are not
independent right
there's correlation in the time series
we expect stock price for for a given
day to be correlated with the stock
price from the previous day as a matter
of fact if we're trying to if we're
trying to to to predict the stock price
from a given day from the previous day
we hope there's correlation if there if
they were independent we the the
prediction wouldn't be very useful
but that this creates a problem for the
bootstrap because in the
previous
in the schematic
we would we were sampling here or we
assumed that the sampling
was iid from the population
but in this situation that's not a
reasonable assumption because
the observations are not independent so
in general when you set up the bootstrap
and and arrange for the sampling you
must uh must figure out what parts of
the data are are independent so one
thing people do in a time series
because the observations
are are not independent or correlated
across time is to use what's called the
block bootstrap
the block bootstrap divides the data up
into blocks
um
and between blocks one assumes that
things are independent
my spelling is not good okay so for
example if we use a block size of three
we might this would be the first block
these three observations these three be
the second block these were the next
block and now our sampling units are not
the individual observations but the
entire blocks so we would sample with
replacement from all the blocks
and then paste them together into a new
time series
whereas this guy's sampled he might
become the first block
second block etc and then we paste them
together in order
and and that becomes a bootstrap sample
to which we apply the same the estimate
in this case a regression model so the
point is you have to sample the things
that are uncorrelated
you have to arrange for or find the
parts the data that are uncorrelated
and use that as the basis for bootstrap
sampling in this case um
we're going to we use a block of size 3
under the assumption that beyond a time
lag of 3
things are somewhat uncorrelated but
within a block we expect correlation so
we keep the blocks intact sample them as
units
that's called the block bootstrap
i say that here okay
so we talked about the bootstrap for
standard errors that's the main the main
use of the bootstrap bootstraps to
estimate the standard errors of an
estimate like the alpha hat in our
investment example
another very common use of the bootstrap
is for a confidence interval
so let's go back to
confidence interval for a parameter
let's go back to slide 29
and remember this is the histogram we
got from the bootstrap for the the
values of alpha hat over bootstrap
sampling 1000 bootstrap samples
if you look at this histogram
a reasonable way to to derive a
confidence interval is take the
percentiles of from this histogram
like suppose i want a 0.9 confidence
interval
so that it contains a true value with
probably 90 percent
makes sense to grab the fifth and 95th
percent quantiles so let's
find the
five percent point of this histogram
and the 95 point of that histogram
there's a thousand points here so
actually the five percent point would be
the
uh
the 50th biggest and 950th biggest value
of the of alpha i mean smallest and
biggest
say that wrong
i'm sure they understood it's okay just
like i mean
okay um
so if we do that that is a provides a
confidence interval for alpha and what
do we actually get i've got the back of
the slide i
was that
so 0.43 and 0.72
so
this is actually a
an appropriate confidence interval for
alpha
and remember
how to interpret this confidence
interval what this means is that if we
do
repeat this experiment from the
population many times
we expect we it would be the case that
the confidence interval that we obtained
would contain the true value of alpha
90 of the time that's what a 90
confidence interval
is we talked about that earlier this
particular way of constructing an
interval is called a bootstrap
percentile interval and there's actually
an entire field of in statistics to do
with confidence intervals in the
bootstrap and there's many many many
papers and books that have written about
this topic this bootstrap percentile
interval is the simplest way of
constructing a confidence interval from
the bootstrap and it's very useful
we just use the histogram of bootstrap
values themselves and use their
percentiles
so we talked about the bootstrap for
let's see for standard errors and
confidence intervals
how about
prediction error like misclassification
error we've seen in the in the course
already
well the major tool we talked about for
that was cross validation
let's think back across validation how
it worked
we have k folds and k4 cross validation
we divide the data up into k parts
let's say five and i'll just draw this
again
and remember what we did here's our five
parts created random
careful cross-validation it's like a
member like a five-act play if ks5 we
at one stage of the play these four are
the training set these four parts
and the remaining fifth part
is the validations part
set
and cross validation fits to the four
parts if it's a model and then uses that
model to to predict the fifth part and
then and in turn we then
uh this guy gets to play the role of the
validation set the next stage and this
guy et cetera and this is five stages
but a crucial part of cross validation
was that when we do one stage like this
there's no overlap between the training
set and the validation set now the
observations in one do not appear in the
other
and that's important because we're
trying to get an idea of test set error
on new data
so cross-validation is using is is is uh
taking a piece of data
separating it out from the training set
so when i fit on this data and predict
on this data this data is a sense new it
hasn't been seen by these by the
training by the model trained on the
first four so there's a separation a
clean separation between training and
validation
well
what if we do try to use the bootstrap
to estimate prediction error let's
let's just draw
again the bootstrap sampling process
here's my training set
and i'm gonna draw draw samples with
replacement from the
training set bootstrap samples each one
of the same size and a few hundred of
them
well
the first kind of obvious idea is to say
well let's let's train on my on a
bootstrap data set and then
predict the the original training set as
my validation set
and do that for each bootstrap sample
each bootstrap sample gets to play the
role of the training set to fit and then
i'm going to predict my original
training sample as my validation set
well there's a big problem with that and
the problem is there's a
an overlap between the
bootstrap data sets and the original
data set
in particular about two-thirds of the
original data points appear in each
bootstrap sample
and you should
think about how to prove this it's not
hard but
it's um
you'll find out that about two-thirds of
the of this of these points
so the training set points are in the
bootstrap sample
this creates a problem because now when
i go when i'm uh i train here and then i
i do the prediction of a training set
two-thirds of the points
um
in this in this training set have
already been seen by them that by the
model
because because they're in the bootstrap
data set so on average there's that this
two-thirds overlap means that most of
the training points are not novel
so
this is a big problem because the the um
prediction error from this process will
be will be will be biased downward it'll
be a lot lower than the actual
prediction error because i'm i'm i'm
predicting two thirds of the points i'm
predicting have already seen in the
bootstrap data set
so this is not a good way of estimating
prediction error
okay i say that it underestimates a true
prediction error quite dramatically
now the other you think about the other
way around you could you could have you
could train on the training set and use
the bootstrap samples as the validation
sets and that's even worse and you can
think about why that is so it's even
worse in the sense it's going to be even
more biased
well how do you fix this problem
you can you can fix it by when you need
when you
train on the bootstrap sample and then
predict the training sample
just recording the predictions for for
the for the points that did not occur in
the bootstrap sample in other words the
points that are actually novel points
but then this gets quite complicated and
in the end it's really not worth it um
if you if you push this idea to its it's
a conclusion you can get something which
is about as good as cross-validation but
it's much more complicated so our view
is
for um
for this particular problem the
cross-validation is
is easier and and better to and the
thing we recommend
um if i can just interrupt rob that
actually brings up an interesting point
a lot of the time we have simple methods
you know like cross validation and then
a new method comes along like using
bootstrap to estimate prediction error
and we see it's quite a lot more
complicated and you don't get much in
return and so our general philosophy is
if you can
if you can get the job done with a
simple method it's far better than using
a more complicated method just because
it maybe looks sexy or whatever so keep
it simple that's the idea